he will try and seize it with white
pregnant may be more classical um we've
seen him just slowly outplay his
opponents before in the past he would
love to just survive the opening get a
playable position
and uh yeah it's going to be fascinating
to see the clash of styles yeah you
could tick the words right out of my
mouth that's what i was predicting as
well a sharp battle in the opening and
uh pragananda
i think you'd be fearsome on the
counter-attack okay so we saw the queen
scan bit the queen's camp it was
declined until now it's uh the catalan
opening and okay still very theoretical
this is well-known theory heavy theory
here if vidit wants a safer game he'll
capture a black pawn now
there we go
the queens are likely to come off
no attack no big sacrifices
um this one's still very well known one
of my favorite lines of the catalan
opening
but vidit it shows he just wants maybe
against a younger player to take it into
quieter waters uh maybe just take the
sting any risk danger out of
out of the play
and here white's knight normally goes
over to attack this black bishop and
white now has a couple of moves i think
vidit has patented pushing his a pawn
forward
in this position but white's sea pawn
could not push forward white's bishop
the dark square bishop could move lots
of choice here
just to mention what happened we saw a
quick trade of pawns it's level material
okay one of the main moves now
it's level material white's pawn
structure a bit shattered on this queen
side white has two isolated pawns on the
left side but white's piece is very very
active so this is regarded as level but
black really needs to know what he's
doing
and okay this move
oh it's one of the most annoying moves
i've ever faced i must admit this rook
move uh when i first saw it i thought i
can't be good for black but the more i
study it the more it looks fine and it
does solve most of black's problems so
let's ignore the evaluation bar for now
just getting a bit excited black was
actually sacrificing a bit of material
but it was well known to be okay for
black but uh what do you think of uh
this move that uh vidit has just played
because i saw that they were following
your game that you had between daniel
friedman the german grandmaster and
there you are you actually paid rook uh
to the sea lion yeah that's because i
didn't really know what i was doing so i
think vidiq knows better um so okay we
see a quick trade of points it looks
like both sides are really well prepared
here and okay the first real imbalance
of the games white has the bishop pair
now if you look at white's two bishops
they're both on the longest possible
diagonals and that might give a small
advantage that being said pieces are
flying off the board getting traded
queens have come off a set of minor
pieces now black pregnant with his last
move trying to trade a set of knights as
well
uh looks like a battle of homework in
this one not much else to say
and okay knights off the board as well
look at the black rooks so white's
bishops are supreme they're very
impressive but those black rooks we
talked about open files kaya this is why
you keep those rooks on open files they
have access to the whole board
all right looks nice with those open
files both players playing super fast
here up to 17 minutes on the clock so uh
would we say that they're in preparation
still even 22 moves into this
certainly looks that way i mean looks
like both players came very very well
prepared because
you see
even when vidin made his poor move
pragananda did not flinch he just kept
on
blitzing out those moves
and
i think that they've worked a path to a
quality and sometimes this is what
happens in top chess you know you play
some kind of line
it's tricky but ultimately if your
opponent handles everything correctly
then it's equal
yeah and i guess it's just a battle of
kind of perspectives here opinions white
has no risk i think white can make a
draw any time he wants maybe even by
trading off a bishop for a night trading
a set of rooks so vidit knows he's got a
safety net but he also knows that the
bishop pair white's bishop pair gives
some small potential for an advantage
later on pragnanda meanwhile he will
have looked at this with a computer i'm
pretty sure
if you look longer with a top top
computer this will say 0.0 and he'll
think okay
the computer trusts it therefore i trust
it and maybe he'll have worked out a
strategy
to completely neutralize the bishop pair
that being said black is the one having
to be more accurate and it's never been
my style personally to memorize 23 moves
of theory to get a slightly worse
position
um but these days the top players they
employ that strategy just to survive as
black and it works very well if you do
survive these types of bang games you
need good end game skills of course
and uh okay did it i like this last move
just creating a safe square for the
white king in front
where this bishop used to stand
so no background checkmates no nasty
surprises for vidit to face
and yeah it's
finally i think both players out of
their homework
well we know pragnanda of course what
he's been doing lately he played in the
air things monsters what has vedic been
up to i suspect he also played in the
fide grand prix
the two first legs um i think yeah of
course he did but unfortunately he
didn't reach
the destination yeah let's say but um
yeah i mean he's a very strong player
very well known and i think both of the
players uh they work on cheers like all
the time it feels like i mean it's all
about chess you can even if i follow uh
the accounts their social media accounts
and i can see that he read it is all the
time he's on the on this training
process yeah i actually heard a quote by
someone that vedic is one of the hardest
working players in the top of chess
yeah i heard that anish was teasing him
that he was maybe the second most hard
working player
but yeah
i think ever since i first met him when
he was a teenager he's been one of the
biggest opening specialists in the world
and in order to become an opening
specialist you need to be a great
researcher a great student you need to
work with other people you need to
analyze deeply on your own not just with
computers and he's done all that so yeah
hard working is a good a good phrase for
him meanwhile a set of rooks are about
to leave the board we will see a rook
trade
everything's coming off the board to be
honest here
not too much the material left
well uh it is a good time for for indian
chest though we know of course after
pregnant on the beats magnus in the air
things monsters huge attention the
indian prime minister it was just crazy
the attention um and also lately
announced that uh chennai will host the
chess olympiad that's right and it will
take place i think the same time times
july august yeah so i know it's it's a
big deal in indian chess and uh to have
a tournament like that i don't think the
olympiad has ever been in india it will
be the first first time ever
and uh this is a big big news yeah and
because we remember right the images
from the match that magnus played
against vishy anand in 2013 just the
crazy attention and just the love for
chess since i've been there in chennai
in 2013.
what was it like oh my god it was the
craziest tournament ever you know like
so much attention we had so many
journalists and uh literally
photographers were jumping on players
and
literally like that so there was a
special corridor police corridor so the
players could come to for the press
conference otherwise he couldn't just
get there
and i mean it was very impressive and i
mean
i keep really interesting memories
from that event i mean apart from the
whole event which was very exciting it
was also a very special atmosphere yeah
yes i mean of course vicia is a hero in
india everybody knows him respects him
and there were also some crazy stories
even that after the press conference
one time the mice disappeared the next
time the keyboard disappeared they
couldn't understand what's going on and
it was disappearing without
let's say the other set like without usb
stick so i couldn't understand what's
going on and then somebody explained me
that if we should touch something it
becomes
like a tie of david very important
something very important so probably
people just wanted to keep it as for
their memories yeah so then we had
police you know
which who make sure that we still have
our uh you know the demise is becoming
worse for the next press conference
so they have interesting memories but
chennai of course it's a very
interesting city and i'm sure that
everybody would love this experience
yeah
and it would be fascinating because as
the hosts india will be able to field at
least two teams and that means they can
be that right with all the talent i've
got so many strong players i think
70-something grand masters now i mean
imagine if fishy plays vidit plays hare
krishna all those guys and imagine if
they have a young young guns team um
full of pragnando gakesh
it's just scary and uh i mean that event
is going to go down in history as one of
the most exciting because india that's
where
a lot of passionate chess fans live
these days yeah will you guys play
uh i i hope i will be commenting so yeah
so i'm not sure
what about you
i'm hoping to play yeah cool
i'm yet to work out the details with the
english federation but i really hope so
cool
and uh if england want me i'm i'll be
there that's service
um yeah if i haven't retired by then but
i'll give it another go it will be nice
to go to india and experience that whole
thing retired your chest high david is
now up to
11 hundred dollars and okay so i just
learned that you know every time a new
bid comes in there is a little bit of
time added a few minutes so that
everyone is uh able to process that uh
bid and potentially make another bit so
it's amazing you guys
wow i mean imagine how much a tie the
vichy war
would go for
maybe that's the next charity uh yes in
tonight
yes actually the attention to the match
was so huge i mean i've never seen
something like that so i hope the same
will be for the olympiad yeah it was
broadcasted on tv i mean everybody in
the city knew who what's going on so i
mean it's really cool yes and i'm a big
fan of the team events you know no
matter what kind of way they're played
it's so much fun to follow the team
events
and in this one well vida definitely
taking some time to think i sort of got
the feeling david that you thought this
could
could fizzle out yeah
do you think vedic is just now
taking his time looking to see is there
anything he can do to keep this game
going i think that's exactly what he was
contemplating and okay we do have a move
let's just show what's happening in the
position maybe to show why i think it's
likely to fizzle out to a draw
usually i'm a huge fan of the bishop
pair i would love these types of bishops
especially on an open board the problem
is there aren't that many targets and
actually there aren't that many pawns
remaining on this side of the board
there's only two pawns here if these get
traded it's just gonna be a draw if
pawns are on one side of the board the
knight can hold its own
everything will be defended by black and
not too much life left but the problem
is after vidic goes after the black pawn
now the black rook steps across and how
do you defend this guy it's just
impossible
it's not only that you can't defend it
it's attacked by the rook but the bishop
can also come and attack it as well and
this pawn will drop no matter what and
if you can't keep this pawn alive it's
unlikely you'll be able to create a pass
pawn on the other side of the board
that's the only way to win the game and
look at this everything's about to get
liquidated eliminated
the bishop dropping back and now after
the black rook captures this born i'm
expecting to see rook takes pawn these
rooks will disappear and the bishop pair
are not so effective when there's only
pawns on one side of the board actually
knights tend to be better than bishops
when there's only pawns on one side of
the board and how are these four ever
gonna creep past blacks four it's just
not gonna be possible pawn's on the same
side of the board
i wouldn't be surprised if these bishops
get traded at some point as well and
just not enough material left for either
side this one it's been really
interesting from a kind of academic
point of view learning about the opening
theory seeing both players doing their
research and kind of testing each
other's memories but
yeah unfortunately not too exciting it
looks like a draw likely in this one and
as predicted let's go back to the
players now because as predicted the
pawns have come off the rooks have come
off
i think we'll see a few more moves but
uh
not too much to say here unfortunately
yeah yeah i i think we'll probably see
the players try to get into an opposite
color bishop end game and then just
repeat moves yeah
and you can tell on the body language
both players pretty relaxed about this
one
whatever i was trying to predict
actually went the other way around so i
mean it was just normal quiet game and
actually kudos to prague for finding all
the best moves i mean or starting all
the best moves in this position
and equalizing the game with black
pieces against such a strong component
yeah and uh i think vidit the main
reason he went for this just kind of
safety first approach is because he won
two of his first three games he's doing
very well in the standings and why take
risks uh maybe vidit thinks okay today
has been exciting enough he's done
really well and a draw is fine whereas
for prague he's doing okay so far one
win one loss but
um with the black pieces against someone
strong like vidic someone really well
prepared a draw is always a decent
result so we can't fault either player
just uh a good result for both of them
it feels like
and also it's
quite late
in india as well so you know it's been a
tiring day so i certainly can
forgive the players for playing
um rather
i mean the thing is though that's not
even true because they did give it their
all it was just a perfect game yeah
neither side making mistakes exactly
yeah and uh okay we've reached move 30.
um it'll be interesting to see
kind of how this game finishes whether
it will be just a repetition of moves
where both sides kind of mutually just
agree no progress to be made or whether
we'll see them kind of battle it out
just trade off everything go for king
versus king eventually
yeah actually it's going to be time
difference in india too for many players
right so
well it's really it's going to be tricky
as well yeah yes i remember myself
playing in indonesia and we just arrived
and we had to start the games and there
were two two rounds per day and i had to
play like at four o'clock in the morning
time and i remember myself like i
couldn't understand where i am what i'm
doing what about chess what's going on
here so sometimes it's really you know
challenging yeah
two rounds a day as well and yes you
couldn't really go and sleep because
there was another round yeah
it's intense i have to say i need those
one game a day seven hour time anything
else is just
too fast
exactly and okay we're racing towards a
draw actually here this one isn't going
to last much longer we see a trade of
bishop for night now it's actually even
opposite color bishops
all the life has been sucked out of this
one white bishop just trying to give
itself up but if black captured it then
white would have been a pawn up in the
end game but no now it's three pawns
versus three pawns and opposite colour
bishops
chess does not get more drawish than
this position
so
okay a hard fight
but just a perfect game and they've
cancelled each other out
a draw any moment now
and they can go to sleep yeah exactly
well deserved break for both players
yeah how easy do you think it is to
sleep
after playing four rounds of exciting
chess
it depends yes
i struggle so i'm not the right person
to ask i can never sleep within two or
three hours of a game i need to wind
down
me too i also also need some time to
kind of change
and
here comes the big repetition yeah three
times the position is repeated itself
it's a draw
all right a draw between india's number
two and there is 16 year old up and
coming superstar pragnanda in game four